weaving his way working his way
underneath new shot clock Kyle they need
that thread from loose land five this
crew right now and Maddy see the
pressure that passed is not a good pass
to the shooter he had to slow down those
ankles to get the bag of the time
Persinger's left the game to come back
in I mean this is a different game took
the speed right now energy seven point
game 6 33 left 20 points for Lowry you
have two guys take four signals out of
that rebound hollis-jefferson Tanaka
noise
make sure the big fella can't get a hand
on Kyle no travel called Hardaway jr.
misfires Boucher fortunately snares in
his sixth rebound Lowry transitions
[ __ ] it book it neither team with a foul
to give
and here here's the key for the rapper's
right now who's bench guys to put some
good minutes in here
[Applause]
Raptors trailed 85 55
he's got 3220 in the corner Minnie Smith
on Lowrey see if he's in attack mode
here
driving kids it up throws it down Carl
our watch he turns the Jets on right
here blue shade the same time saw his
man go down he just trailed on to play